The other Python feature I want to introduce now is default parameters. Default
parameters allow us to have parameters that don't necessarily need to be passed
in. This is very handy. So, here's an example to illustrate the value of default
parameters. Remember that we defined the dish class and it's initializer takes
three parameters in addition to the self object. A name, a price and
description. But there's some dishes that are so famous that they don't need a
description. Either that or they defy description. So, suppose that applies to
our Bodacious Burger. We could pass in None or some empty string or some other
value, but really, we don't want to pass in anything. We don't want to have a
description. That's okay if we have just one parameter that we don't care about.
But suppose we have lots of them. Then, we might end up needing to do something
like this. We've got 1, 2, 3, 4 parameters we don't care about, we've got to
remember to have those. And then, we've got one that we do care about, say that
is the number of side dishes that comes with the Bodacious Burger. And we want
that to have a value 3. And then, we've got to remember another one that we
don't care about. This gets to be pretty unwieldy, the way we're going to avoid
this is to give default values for the parameters. And then, we only have to
pass in the ones that are different from the default values. The way to do this
is quite simple. For each parameter that we want to have a default value, like
the description parameter, we just add an assignment giving it the value that we
want it to have. So, the description parameter will have a default value None.
If we don't pass in a description, it will have the value None. If we pass it
in, it will have the value that we pass it. Then, we can use a note like this,
creating new instances of the Dish class. Only passing in parameters whose value
differs from the default value. We always have to pass in the name and price
because they have no default value, and those are the first two in both calls
here. But otherwise, we don't have to pass in anything else unless we want a
value different from the default value, like we do here with the Broccoli
Burger, which is vegetarian, the default value is False. For the Bodacious
Burger, we didn't pass in any value for vegetarian, that means it will have the
default value which is False. And it's highly non-recommended for vegetarians.